of the final session with the second
part of Daniels talk on quantum
many-body physics in fact the
computational complexity of it that's it
thank you mean and today I would want to
talk about three things first what are
the old different local hamiltonians
that were interested in the ones that
are really difficult but also the ones
that are kind of easier and then what
are the ones where we have algorithms
for them and what are we doing in
practice to find these ground state
energies focusing on mostly heuristics
in the algorithms and then finally I'm
going to ask the question of when we
have these Hamiltonians what are they
used for can we use them to build a
computer or can we use to simulate one
quantum system with another quantum
system so first we start with a question
about local Hamiltonian is the ground
state energy use some local Hamiltonian
small one thing that all problems can be
difficult can be characterized whether
their solutions can be efficiently
verified on a classical computer or
maybe on a quantum computer so like a
problem like this you've got a
Hamiltonian cycle you've got a board and
you're supposed to make a tour of the
board with a chess do night so that you
end up at the same spot and this is how
you do it and I just convince you so
that's easy quantumly here's we have a
quantum circuit and I'm asking a
question is there a state that I can
feed into this circuit so that the
circuit will accept it I need someone
see us in there and the class 2 ma is
the class of problems that have these
verifier circuit which accept good
proofs with high probability and when
they're don't accept anything then we
have bound that they don't accept
anything with probability higher than
something now the local Hamiltonian can
be shown that it's as hard as this
program and this problem is really can
we fit something into the circuit so
that outputs one and the way that this
is done is that somehow we need to
encode a computation into a ground state
of a hamiltonian well what is a
computation a computation is a sequence
of steps that something is happened
and then a computation gets done
classically we can really verify every
step of this computation in a simple way
like this we have strengths and then we
compute on the strings and really
something has happened and we can verify
that these bits are the same and these
are not and then the next step they're
just like a little thing that has
happened and we can verify this and this
is the basis of the Conclave interior
and we're really you put bits on every
wire circuit and then you compare
whether they're actually evaluate it
correctly and you change it to three
sided with local Hamiltonian is slightly
different the reason for that is when
you have states that are quantum you
cannot really compare them when their
product states we have a swab test so
even if they're super positions we make
a swap and we can check that the state
is the same or different ones however if
a state is entangled it's a
superposition or something that like for
example like a cat state 0 0 0 plus 1 11
and now we switch just one bit we get a
mess we cannot really compare that these
days are the same so the way to solve
this problem is when we want to compare
two states which may be differ only by a
single spot somehow I want to compare
them locally I need to get another
register the register will be called a
clock and then for example when the
clock runs something happens to my data
and now I can compare to states like
these just by looking at the clock and
by looking at the data so for example
when the clock runs forward something
happens on the data when the clock runs
backwards something is uncompleted on
the data and then i can look not on the
whole state which might be much bigger
here in much bigger here but i will just
look at the one spot and at the clock
and if this is possible to do locally
then we can verify step in a computation
so really a computation quantumly is
encoded in something like this you've
gotta work register this is where the
computation gets done and here's a clock
register something that kind of drives
this computation this was Feynman's idea
then used in Quetta ops group of tacoma
completeness of local
Tony and the great idea then is that you
take a uniform superposition over the
whole computation and this uniform
superposition is the history state in
it's a very special state which we can
make into a ground state of a particular
sum of many terms and then this creates
this local Hamiltonian so that we can
write k local conditions so that
whenever there is a state in the all a
particular state of the computation then
there needs to be the next state in the
computation just like the clock goes
forward and the data gets computed on
and then there are more things that we
need to do you look there's this clock
register that I just as watch but I need
to do it you know terms of like local
spins or something so you need to check
whether the clock is proper and then you
need to check whether the state for
example is a computation that is
accepted so you look at whether it's
properly initialized and you look
whether it's accepted at the end and
this all together gives us a que local
Hamiltonian for which we can have the
question is its ground state energy law
whether whenever there is an accepted
computation or it's gonna say the energy
is high if there is nothing that the
original circuit which we're trying to
check its verification on Tess computing
the hard part is making the clock local
and somehow interesting all strategy is
that in the yes cases if we had a
circuit that you could feed something in
that the circuit would accept the ground
state energy would be low in the other
cases if there's nothing that the
circuit would accept then we need to
find a lower bound on the energy and the
way to do this is that we take the whole
Hilbert space and we divide the Hilbert
space in two states that have clocks
that are somehow proper and the clocks
that are improper then we forget about
that part then we look at all these
states here that have proper clocks and
some of them are uniform superpositions
or like history states and some of them
are not history states so we forget
about these and within the states with
history states the hard part or
something that I would like to get rid
of
is that within that there's a
Hamiltonian restricted to the subspace
has a polynomial a small gap that goes
like 1 over l squared where L is the
number of gates it's a it's linearized
so if I need to kind of like put all the
gates in a circuit in order and this
Hamiltonian corresponds to point and
walk on a line or maybe you wanna also
on a side so if we could get away from
this will be nice and then with the
history state you just divided into the
states that were properly initialized
and improperly initialized and then
you've got the well initial ID histories
that possibly might be accepted States
or my not this might be two different
sub spaces and then in the no cases when
nothing is accepted well so no well
initialize history and computation is
accepted then you need to find a lower
bound a lower bound on two different
Hamiltonians where one of them is saying
did we compute correctly and the other
one is did we accept the computation and
there are geometric bounce that you can
put in and then we can go more much more
into the details but in the end this is
the result you have a circuit and you
ask can I heat something in here that
will be accepted in the no case the
circuit doesn't accept anything likely
and it transforms into the local
Hamiltonian problem where any state has
an energy that's higher than something
well if the circuit accept something
likely then there is a state the history
of a computation which is accepted and
its energy is low one of the tools
that's used there that's very useful is
a projection limit so it all it's when
you have a big term and you are that
most of it has a ground space and a
higher energy space and you add a small
turn to that Hamiltonian then the
spectrum divides and we know that the
low energy states definitely need to
come from this substance so we can get a
bound on the eigenvalues of the sign of
these terms by looking only at the small
term restricted to the ground state
subspace of the big term so something
just like this
so for example if I have a term the
little term look like this and the
ground state subspace of the big term
that looks like this that are you know
unary terms then really these
interesting points will come only from
transitions where the one gets
transformed into a zero here or one gets
transformed into a zero here from this
term and never from one going away here
this is one of the main tools that has
been used in taking Kataya orijinal five
local Hamiltonian down to a three local
Hamiltonian and then there's much more
that we need to work on so that we take
the three local interactions and we make
effective three local interactions out
of two local interactions so you put in
three more spins and I want to have a
300-point direction and I make these
three spins to bead want to be the same
either all of them looking this way or
all of them looking that way and if
there is a small interaction here the
small interaction here kind of this kind
gets never flip unless all of them get
flipped because there's all types
together so in an in the end the beast
you will feel it and all together you
will get an efficient and effective
three local interaction out of two local
interactions however what comes in there
is just another energy scale that you
really need these interactions to be way
way stronger and all together this
reflects in the promise or like how
about in the question how well do we
need to approximate the ground state
energy so when way stronger is like a
polynomial I don't know whether it's
like L to the three or L to the five or
something because here on that picture
there's only one one particular
interaction but in the end if you want
the whole construction to go through you
need these intro or directions to be as
strong it needs to take into account the
whole whole competition in your views
picture you
that has certainly got that you're
adding small amazon you know how to do
weights there it to be related to
possibly so they're like all in indy in
the very end like we had some some gap
and then like we edit terms that could
make a mess so we had to make sure that
whatever you re adding is just smaller
than what we had before so what has been
done with this then is we have we have
the local Hamiltonian problem where
we're asking about the global minimum of
many many terms the best result
currently known for is for two local
interactions on a 2d grid by all Roberto
elevator and bad monitor how from 0 0 4
0 0 5 so this is to local Hamiltonian
four cubits in 2d or two local
Hamiltonian on the line so just nearest
neighbor interaction on a line in 1d
where the particles have dimension eight
one of the problems that we really don't
know the answer for is something below
this so for example we don't know the
answer to how hard it is to approximate
the ground state energy of a spin chain
of qubits we don't know how hard it is
we don't know whether we can encode a
computation with a quantum circuit into
it I don't really think so can we even
encode a computation with a classical
circuit into it you don't know either we
know that when the hamiltonian is gapped
we have an algorithm we've heard from
that about this but what if it's just
frustrated and we do have no promise
about the gap of the hamiltonian itself
then we don't know of course you've got
to hear a little bit later about the
great success of the DMR g method which
really count as matter people will say
like we can solve anything just 11 d
with space with a spin one house so I
really want to turn our attention to
problems that are somehow intermediate
that are not that easy we don't have
algorithms for them yet but it's highly
doubtful that we're going to be
encode the full quantum computation into
them so problems that might not be p.m.
a complete and I'm going to give you a
small example of something that I find
interesting but then also maybe not just
classical but somehow natural acquired
also something that I would like to get
away from is these this clockwork
register construction could we get
something else there so that we really
are not bound by this run over l squared
gap all the time 11 way also just not
doing it just directly as a clock and
work register is doing with the
geometric clock that's all my Ewing
constructions by arenas l and done then
lead our or for example in the
universality of adiabatic quantum
computation by law written self and
others where we got particles that are
kind of jumping down the grid may be
together maybe one by one and reading
where the particles are this is my data
that runs through a computation and as
it jumps it gets computed on so this is
a geometrical construction and also yes
well two days ago we were discussing
whether something like this is on a
general graph where it's like really
just anything connected to anything it
turns out that you can actually make
these constructions so that they're
really geometrically local so that a
particle is interacting only with a
constant number of particles that are
nearby and really nearby an embeddable
in 3d space and the way to do it is that
for example you this is your data and
the data kind of wants to jump down the
grid and the clock the clock register
can be wound around around this
physically this way so that like if when
you go this way you compute so as the
clock progress is like 11 1000 and then
when the clock goes kind of backward
then you make these particles jump in a
grid and then you do do this over and
over and then every particle like every
data particle is not like here is
interacting with all the possible clocks
at all possible times but it only tracks
with a few clock particles and only with
another few data particles around it so
geometrical em
embedding into 3d with a constant number
of things as possible and finally it is
possible to do this construction in 1d
on a line this is what in my in talks I
sometimes call it like the dog pick up
ahead put it on your head put it down on
the ground jump over it and kick it back
technique so jump overhead kick it back
it puts it on the on the head puts it
down and it goes goes back and so the
data which heroes moving down the grid
now the data is moving on a line and if
you look at it really the rules like
what's happening it's always only two
places that are changing and with
something that's slightly more
complicated you will get the iron ore
got this money running kempe
construction for the power of control
systems on the line so I'm asking for a
different construction or possibly for
problems that would have stronger
promise on the or that would allow for a
stronger promise so that will be larger
gaps within the Hamiltonians themselves
and a larger promise get possibility of
having non trivial problems that are
somehow intermediate that don't really
encode qma and then of course some other
interesting heart problems so that would
not go directly from the translation
from the circuits something that I was
talking about two days ago one of the
problems that for example we know that
is difficult is the computation of
electronic structure in quantum
chemistry so the computation goes like
this unit you've got electrons that are
impossible in many orbitals in many a in
a in a molecule that has lots of atoms
and then you need to fit them in there
the possibility for the orbitals we now
know that from chemistry that are only
like SP and higher whatever and then
we've got many electrons that you need
to fit in there so that's like em
orbitals and electrons so there's
possible M over N it can be a huge
number so the whole computation is can
be really if you do the full
configuration interaction
which means that you really do it
exactly it's is horrible so we can
really do it for very small molecules so
if we want to do this one of the ways to
solve it is something called the density
functional theory and it's instead of
solving for electrons that are
interacting you transform your problem
into another fictitious program where
you only solve for the electron density
and so where the electron actually don't
know about each other but to make this
new fictitious problem is a hard thing
in general just because it's qm a
complete as shown by James Whitfield all
know that you can't Frank I started
because you can take if you could solve
this problem then you can solve stuff
with interacting electrons for example
the Hubbard model and with the Hubbard
model you can simulate the Heisenberg
model and with the Heisenberg model you
can solve the two local Hamiltonian or
that progressively kind of weaker so
that means like you really you will not
be able to find the density the
universal density functional what about
if we don't want to find it exactly but
we won't find an approximation so for
example like with the hartree-fock
method that one is np-complete in
general so this tells you that like in
the worst-case quantum chemistry
computations are really difficult but we
really don't know how it is on average
or in real life molecules and again
maybe this will be instances of problems
that might be doable like just when we
talked about the condensed matter
problems where in general the problem is
really difficult but specifically for
example here there are fields external
fields which don't actually exist in all
in the molecules sorry so when you say
very [ __ ] is that the same is being
field theory somehow is it a heuristic
curve of
I don't know I don't know eh another
thing that when you're solving for for
this electronic structure maybe we're
really wanting to we're getting the wave
function but if you don't want the wave
function if you're just only interested
in like reduced density matrices maybe
that would be easier but we also know
that this problem is difficult because
this is related to the Android present
ability that like given a few reduced
density matrices does this correspond to
a full state and we know that one is
also clearly complete by the chi-you
others a standard practice now let's go
to the variance of local Hamiltonian
what are the ones that we can we can
look at first stochastic Hamiltonians
stop passing Hamiltonians are
Hamiltonians where the off-diagonal
elements have the same sign or negative
sign those are not Universal for quantum
computation or at least we don't know
that they are but these are the ones
that we can actually implement in
superconducting architecture for quantum
computers another one and now easier to
I don't know whether options that
there's a reason it's just really like
for example you have a you have a
circuit and you have a circuit and then
this one is making magnetic field and
this one is or registering it so it's
easier to make like a desert interaction
but to make an interaction that will be
set and an ex while being able to do the
other one is no it's not that easy no it
just means we don't really know how like
we don't know a physical realization so
in the in the constructions in the
practical superconducting architecture
we only have particular interactions
that are available and ones that we've
got our only the ones on the side at the
moment I second interesting or subclass
of local hamiltonians are the ones with
the community hamilton's this also what
all that was
talking about with we've got the aerial
ace and so they've been investigated by
driving in the alley which has shown
that when you've got to local commuting
hamiltonians the problem is in a deep
when you're looking at black cats into
decent like you've got four things some
projectors or or commuting terms on four
spins at a time it's in NP when you've
got three local interactions with q-bits
dotted and Ollie or have shown that it's
all in NP when you've got cute traits
and the geometries kind of like planar
and something special it's also easy one
thing that I want to point out though
that the commuting Hamiltonians are not
just something that's this really some
of classical day really encode
interesting quantum things because the
community Hamiltonians are for example
the Torico the guitar story called or
we've heard from ben ricardo yesterday
about stabilizer codes where you get
again like terms that are commuting and
are together there eigen space creates a
code another thing that's interesting
about commuting hamiltonians that we've
got the constructive lavas local lemma
proof by martin schulz and others and by
italian or from last year we're really
we have an algorithm to find the ground
state but it's a with the conditions of
the lowest local emma so that means if
there are not too many conditions on
each of the spins and the conditions
themselves are commuting then there is a
way to find the ground state and the way
it really goes like to construct a local
law as local emma classically or like
the something like that walks out
algorithm that you take make a
projection if you succeed you continue
and if you fail you just take that away
and put in a random state and keep doing
this keep doing this and keep doing this
and you will converge if there are not
too many conditions on each thing but we
really don't know how this works when
you've got many conditions on each pin
we don't know how it work for not
commutative ones really there is a lack
of a natural even really badly scaling
algorithm that will find
States for quantum systems especially
because when you're looking at something
that's not commuting so for example you
check here that this condition is met
very well but then the next you check
whether the next condition is met there
may very well and it's not and it can
mess up something in here you don't I
don't know which which one goes first
which one goes later it's it's a mess
also we don't really have algorithms
that will work like this for even simple
problems so there's an algorithm for
quantum to set by sega rally that's
classical but when you try to do an
algorithm like this which like project
and if you don't succeed do something
and if you project and if you succeed
keep going we even don't have an
algorithm like that for full quantum to
set which we know is easy classically so
shall be chemo and edifier you have been
working on this and they have shown that
an algorithm I like that works for just
only a restricted class of quantum two
sub problems so there's a lot that needs
to be done there even for simple
hamiltonians christian yes so sir when
you're saying this constructive know
what about local yeah so do you mean you
have polynomial time in classical
amerson so there's a polynomial time is
it because it's a quantum algorithm it's
really you take you project you may have
to make a quantum measurement and then
if you don't succeed you have to put in
a random quantum state on that sub sub
system but which is how you compare the
conditions from this
to you know there you have harnessed
result for MP like still commuting the
true logo so how can I compare it to
this result with you we know it's so
commuting it's in NP Oh the thing is
that here there's a there's only few
conditions so it's a special condition
on top so every every particle is
interacting only with a very involved in
only very few terms so it's kind of like
when there's few terms something works
everything the harness case for the two
local NPR news they have a very strong
connection it's general there's no no
restriction on how many things you can
be involved but I'm referring in the
dish approve the harness by really
constructing something concrete right so
in that country example I mean of course
it was should now satisfy the condition
from this I just want to see a hug oh
you know what's my scapula I don't
really know maybe way we can discuss
with or who was one of the authors where
that touches to see what what what will
the detail different stairs okay so
let's leave leave that for now another
class is where you've got restricted
terms so only particular terms of like
saying like or Jinky Montana Peter love
have shown that when you got X Z and X
and something then it's universal but
now we've got the Dakota dichotomy
theorem bio by Toby and Ashley where it
showed that like particular terms
everything is easy if you've got these
types of terms this problem really is
like a 20 Hamiltonian is as hard as dead
and it's difficult and then finally
there's a variant where you've got a
fixed interaction so the same
interaction between the particles but
the graph interaction graph is different
and this is the most recent result about
the EMA completeness of the both
hyper-model by andrew charles david
gossett exact map another variant is a
variant without frustration so that's a
quantum case our program I said gay
travel so imagine that you don't have
terms and you're a thief or global
ground state but you'll get projectors
there's my cupboard space and I'm
projecting stuff out and projecting
projecting projecting and I'm asking is
there a common ground state of all of
the
so is there anything left after I
project out with all of these projectors
is there a state that's simultaneously
killed by all this is quantum case it so
this is really like an hour all set
classical set while the local
Hamiltonian is analog of Max's up and
the result here for the am frustrated
set is that when you've got to local
interactions between five dimensional
and three-dimensional particles by your
elder or the Vega this is qma one
complete because you can really certify
things because you have to exhibit a
state where it really is killed by all
of these projectors and on a line you
need 11 dimensional cute it's on a line
but how does it look when you get on
frustrated problems in smaller
dimensions or really just not spin spot
cute rates this is something I'm
interested in and also night when you
have three level interactions four
cubits of this is the quantum three son
this is the recent result of david
gossett me another question that we can
look at is random quantum sense so just
like classical we can look at random
instances of all satisfiability then we
just put if we don't have many
conditions the instance will be
satisfiable you can put in more and more
more projectors and suddenly distance
becomes unsatisfied and what we have
realized that when you have quantum said
this is the number of solutions there
are definitely parts that are like
classical instances and quantum
instances make classic intense instances
have more solutions than the quantum
instances so we can actually show that
when there's a particular classical
instance on a given graph that has no
solutions it really means that the
generic quantum case is also unsolvable
so we can bound quantum set by classical
adversary set and oh this is a word from
Antonio's Colicchio and knock on our
door shuts last year I want to focus
more on one dimension so what happens in
one dimension in one dimension you can
have local hamiltonians whose ground
states are uniform super
of things like what i call surfers on a
domain wall so here spins up spins down
and here's a surfer that rides the way
and universe superposition of these is
the ground state and it's not very
entangled it actually has smit Rank 2
and you can do this with a to local
Hamiltonian on the line with Euclid's
and you can do more than that on a line
if you increase the size of the local
particles and that's the power of
quantum systems on a result by Lloyd are
no they don't go to this month's end
irani enjoy a campaign and there it is
the thing that I showed with their hats
that you've got some part of the chain
that kind of enclose the data and the
data can possibly move the data moves
forward and then jumps over something
and move forward again and as it moves
forward then a computation can get done
all the data and again the data will try
to move a little bit to go move forward
and then a computation will get done
somewhere later and all this unit from
superposition over all these things will
be a possible ground state of this local
Hamiltonian and we can show that if this
state exists and has a low energy it
corresponds to an accepted computation
so again the problem with 13 dimensional
particles on the line is qm a complete
so with next nearest neighbor with
nearest neighbor interactions and the
ground state is entangled because when i
make a cut that these are basically like
the schmidt the states this is a like a
straight basis and even there's even
more like what you need to really divide
this because this could be a very
entangled state but also when you run
instead of a quantum verification you
run an NP verification a classical
circuit then these things are not very
entangled but all together there is a
polynomial number of states here in the
superposition because there are all
these states where the computation is
gone all the states where the
computation is not not had been there
yet and these like polynomial in n
states in here while the computation is
running through this cut
for which the azaleas so for Cade oh is
that all there we have here in this
particular construction there are no
illegal transitions which means that we
have stronger promises and the program
could possibly be unrestricted well with
the eight we're introducing these best
transitions and things that are the cure
when you do the analysis of the of
what's happening in the dynamics is not
really a walk on a line it's a work on
the line and like possibly some some
jumps away so you have to be much more
careful so somewhere different in
different promises no you need a
stronger stronger promises sorry a
stronger promise in this case higher
precision for the D equals 8 yep so this
is though you can trade parity for local
dimension and go down to 11 I've shown
this in a two thousand eight and then
really with Sean husband and son Dean
and a sign we have shown that you can go
down to eight dimensional particles and
the program still stay square may
complete but now becomes frustrated so
you need a better precision or the
question is look like a tie is the
ground state energy more than this or
greater than this with much smaller box
and this construction has been then used
for some all for this translation
variant hamiltonians where somehow you
have a a grid on which you can have a
computation that runs and writes down
what the competition is doing that it
writes down the size of the grid and
then you've got a second layer of
computation that takes down that number
and does the computation that's encoded
in this number so you like to run a
universal Turing machine on the program
that the first machine has done and this
is done in a big grid depending on what
how big the grid is that computation you
will run but when this really needs huge
cute it's because there's like two
layers and many possible states and this
number booth is multiplied there and
then what's also
they're it's not really when we say that
translation variant Hamiltonians rqm a
complete it's not that simple it is that
to make X complete so you look at it
like an n times n grid then you can run
a computation of size log N and this is
all in general in the worst case so when
I asked you the question what is the
ground state energy of a translation
invariant Hamiltonian four cubits or
spins one half on a 2d lattice this
might be easy really the problem that we
know is hard is that when they're
exponential size lattices and the local
dimension is very very high Oh for this
one I don't think they even did that but
it's a lot would be cool if brought down
so let me just tell you about the local
dimensions in one week so when we do
something with 1d we know for
translation invariant states with 21
dimensional I maybe I brought it down to
14 is that you got very entangled states
for unfrosted you'll save money with 11
you can do quantum computation or its
QMI one complete for four dimensions is
very entangled for eight dimensions
frustrated it's qm a complete for too
long for two dimensions so that means
for cube it's the problem is easy
because they're always product safe than
our ground states and 43 we have found
something that for cute rates so when
you have an Hamiltonian that's on a line
nearest neighbor interaction and I'm
asking is there a state that is killed
by all of these terms is it any
interesting is it hard to find it or not
yes
so your bands they are higher than oq so
here we're finding a state that's not
that entangled it's somewhat integral
but but here this this is like hmm this
is a fact translation this is
transaction very young the distance is
here are the same so it's a particular
Hamiltonian that has the same
interaction everywhere and if the ground
set is quite entangled it's not as in
technology cook yeah this is a good good
catch so here the active the entropy
will be much bigger so this is this is a
suggestion what why don't we look at
cute rates for putrid all like this is
our bracket construction that you say
here so this is something a little
that's like indicative of a critical
system where the entropy goes like log l
and but we can make a construction when
we have an hamiltonian that's unfair
ated has so nearest neighbor interaction
has a unique ground state that's that
entangled so the way to do it is that i
bet to local terms where that allow for
brackets to be created on a line
brackets to move around online or just
disappear and the ground state of this
hamiltonian is a uniform superposition
overall well bracketed words this is
this is how the ground state looks like
so it's not a computation in a circuit
but it's just the superposition overall
well bracketed words and this is a
hamiltonian that is a fantastic ground
state its unique fighting tangled and
it's protected by a 1-over polynomial
get new surprises its own cross through
the surprise that is I'm frustrated ever
either pretty cool definitely definitely
we knew critical chains that have this
type of scaling but this is on
frustrated and you would think that an
frustrating problems are somehow easy
what does it mean to be critical so
critical classically means that like the
program you're changing parameters and
like everything is easy correlations
fall down exponentially and then you hit
a hit a spot where suddenly the
correlations blow up or would go like
the correlation length becomes the
vinnitsa like really this part on system
with ice quality with this part of the
system so expect that you really need a
matrix product state with a large
dimension to describe the state so for
example here we are really need matrix
plan I stayed with only polynomial
dimension to describe this it will we
actually know what what that is but this
is without any like changing parameters
this is without Anna generally you have
it like a phase transition when there is
a competition between two types of
interaction terms so some kind of
frustration and we don't have any
frustration here so I'm suggesting let's
look at things in a lower dimension so
this is for cute rates for something
where we can encode not at full
computation but some may be a weaker
model so here the model could be
possibly push down automata so like you
can encode all the things that you can
calculate with pushdown automata in
within the ground states of cute red
chips I don't know whether this is true
but i'm looking for something like this
possibly because we don't know we don't
even know whether we could go and call
something that's like a classical
computation on a in a stinking spin one
object okay let's change gears now and
go turn into the algorithms that we've
got so really to find the ground states
of local hamiltonians so I've shown that
we've got we've talked that we have the
algorithm for one big gap check spin one
half chains where is it also only for
spin one half or is it for higher as
well high as well okay so just one day
and get we have an algorithm for quantum
to set and we have an algorithm for a
quantum algorithm for an almost
independent commuting case so that a
particle is not involved in two min
that's that's all that these are
provable and then we've got lots of
heuristics there are lots of lots of
letters in there and i'm just going to
explain about what they do because this
is what we need really do in practice
because the corners matter people want
to investigate the quantum chemists want
to investigate their systems so what is
it that we actually are doing even
though we know that in the worst
the problems are ridiculously difficult
so for example what what is the DMR G
Afghan if this is my possum my possible
basis so this is a computational basis
state for it spins one half on the chain
but instead of looking at the full basis
let me just divide the system and like
look at it like left part and the right
part and then just a single single spin
and I have a I have the full basis but
let's not work with the food bases let's
just make it smaller bases and choose
just these states now let's try to find
something within this Anton's and the
way that we gonna do it that if I choose
just these states then each of these
states has some some cost like maybe
this one like when it interacts with a
spin up it so it will raise the energy a
little bit when this one interacts with
the spin down with the energy will go
down a little bit so we try to do our
best within a basis so we've got these
prices for these for these bases basis
States and we try to combine you so for
example there's a Hamiltonian term that
interacts like this one with this one so
we put put these things down and then we
make an effective Hamiltonian within
this basis then we solve it and we
really find the best state you do this
with the lantern algorithm because this
Mel Hamiltonian could be stars and the
very important thing is that you don't
really actually calculate the
Hamiltonian that you only in the lancet
algorithm you need to calculate you take
a vector and you multiply the vector and
multiply the vector never really make
the matrix price is the price the price
would be like though the price for a
particular basis state would be that
what's the Hamiltonian on the first
Hamilton 12 plus a mutant in 23 plus
Amazonia 34 that are not involved in
anything that basically like it's the
energy of the left left state so you're
a little locklear that's like
whatever is what it's a quantum state
it's a quantum state on the on the left
part of the system but it's it's a party
it's a party color particular state that
I choose so I choose that let's find out
what's the best state that we can find
if we can do whatever on the metal spin
then only these possible states on the
right side and only these possible
states on the left side so with the
restricted basis within some sub
hundreds yeah definitely like we choose
DD of those like some number really in
practice we choose a thousand so instead
of like to to the size of the left arm
system you choose just a thousand states
which thousand so that's a question you
start you start without really somehow
on the left and you choose like spin up
spin down then you make a next step and
you need to choose something from two
states so you still choose four states
and you keep going and at some point
just have to start throwing stuff away
and i'll tell you how to produce throw
stuff away so within a particular basis
we make an effective hamiltonian and
then we find the best stay with what
we've got sorry what you keep on the
right so on the right is again some list
of states that i have gotten from before
yes only on the left you started with
everything and you kept throwing out
right I'll tell you I'll tell you so let
me let me just tell you never now that
you give me states you can be stated and
I try to find what's the best that I can
do with it so you do your best and then
I asked the state that I got is it very
entangled or not so I do a Schmidt
decomposition along this line so I
Schmidt a composition so now these
states become orthogonal now and you do
the Schmidt decomposition by just doing
like a radius density matrix or the
subsystem and really diagonalizing it so
this is a shemitah compost best state
with the best that I've got and then I
just truncate the state because I look
at least that these things are small so
I forget about some of the states in
here it's still a pretty good state and
really what's been left it's still a
pretty good basis this
a pretty good basis for the left part of
the system and there will be a pretty
good basis for the right part of the
system dude is a few times no just one
so I will show you how how did a few
times so really what has to happen that
instead of having the states that you
gave me and my particle I now have the
new States new basis that I have chosen
for your part plus the particle so I
have grown a block and I will call this
the new basis for this part choice
you'll leave lender you're disregarding
the introduction with the right side I'm
not disregarding interaction altogether
I'm just disregarding some part part of
it like the ones where the left is not
very entangled with the right so the
terms that are just very small so I'm
expecting only a few terms to matter but
when you grow it by one particle you're
not you know you're not taking into
consideration the interaction of the
particle to the right side probably with
the left when I'm growing the block oh
yeah there are there particular things
that are corresponding to this on the
right but I'm actually not going to keep
them so it is in the moment I'm only
interested in like how the left basis is
changing so i got i got a new basis on
the left and then what happens i will
recalculate like how much this new basis
costs the effective Hamiltonian left
part and then i will put in a new video
i ask you for a new basis of one less
particle on the right put in a new new
state and continue so then i will again
find the best with what i can do here
this was knew this was old let me let me
just show you graphically what's
happening imagine that i start with four
particles and then I will do I will
recalculate and find the best find the
best basis I will push them apart try to
put in two new particles in recalculate
then I'll get new basis for like the
left party for the right hand and push
them apart like this
well this is let's let's do this for a
transaction variant system so this is
how I can grow the system up grow the
system and now I start something that's
called that's the bill type let me call
the sweeping part that I have done let's
do the best within this basis and find a
new basis for that part of the system
and then you I call these guys and put
them here and try to combine them and I
put two new particles in and try to see
what's the best that I can do within
this basis I basically do the Schmidt
decomposition here throw up some terms
and only leave like what's useful for
this part and keep going to the right
and I'm making new basis for the left
part and then I do the decomposition
here and now I grow from this side so I
make a big state bigger list of a seat
sit here and i will use up an old one
from there and you keep going like this
in the system there and back sweeping
around and leaving behind you stuff that
you have just calculated and this is an
iterative process that allows you to
find very very good approximations to
the ground States but also too excited
states of local hamiltonians in a while
really what's the success is it is it
that good a critical benchmark would be
a critical system like the anti-fairy
meeting has emerged chain and when you
take like a hundred spits on a line you
take 300 basis States you keep 300 you
do just once week there and back this
all happens in minutes then you get like
arrow that's 10 to the minus 30 it works
fantastically for the worst state of
worst systems that we can imagine is the
algorithm randomizer and we need to
choose these base states on both sides
the deterministic the way so in the
bigot is deterministic yep so in the
beginning it really it can matter like
what you want to start with so for
example one of the good ways to start
was try to build the system up not just
start with a completely random steak and
then start sleeping so it helps to start
smartly and it also really helps if you
also take some physics into account and
if you know
that you're hemel tony has some symmetry
so it really divides into block diagonal
structure so you don't really need to do
everything in so thus 10 to the minus 13
error is that for sold model or how do
you know that this is so we know that
it's for the so brutal and then we owe
the converter that we know how much
things are changing how much the energy
is changing when we're making the
matrices bigger and bigger so you can do
the computation in days and you can put
tens of thousands and nothing as nothing
is changing so we conclude that the
energy has converged how do you know you
have come into a ground state rather
than you know some local doctor over
again we tested on the systems that we
have exactly solved and we tested a
consistence where we have other
numerical methods and really the stuff
that we're getting by this your
heuristic is the best precision that we
can that we have so right now other
things are tested compared to this at
the moment for one-dimensional chase it
gets harder when you get bigger spins so
for example in the hybrid model when
you've got fermions that are interacting
so you can imagine that you have like
four dimensional particles at each site
so then it gets harder and get slower or
when the geometry is known a tree-like
and also it converts slower when you
have open boundary conditions so really
like the boundaries somehow matter so
you have to go to one boundary carries
up to the next boundary and keep keep
going a couple times this this gets
slower and we know that when the spins
become really big we know what when they
when they become like eight dimensional
this is like you make a big problem but
for speeding on half it's working great
for like three dimensional particles
it's working great
okay so with excitations so here when we
were looking for the best that we could
do within a basis but we can also choose
like let's let's keep the best five
states within a given basis so you can
keep you don't have to do just look at
the ground so you can have several
states because it can only do only the
bottom view yeah only the bottom view
exactly but that's what is interesting
it's a good review is so we show that
could they not be imagined the a
geometric scholastics you can look look
at that one thing that you were asking
also in the lectures before is that what
happens when we do something not on your
life so when I have a like a 2d grid you
kind of like thread a line through it
but then you see that like your kooky
black this is just one more this is
another blog indeed under two particles
the Dominican inside but really these
guys could be very correlated so somehow
you need to carry the correlations or
through it here so you have to keep a
lot of states so that you capture that
so for example what's happe what's done
it's a possibly go stuff has been
calculated on all cylinders that are
very long but really like this diameter
is a or circumstances small like on a
cargo mellitus that's a really about
something that appears in condensed
matter a lot and all what's been
calculated that you see that this number
of states that you keep is 200 to 600 or
8000 and you start with some assumption
that this is on this lattice that there
are you going to get something like a
hexagonal lines bond crystal they're
like these things will appear this is
how the spins like each other or like
how much they appear in a singlet there
and then when we increase the number of
states we realize that it goes away and
what happened what shows here it's
something called the spin liquid this is
a recent work by Yahoo's in what and
what happens when they did this the
energy like Goes Down Goes Down Goes
Down and that it sound like 2000 it
jumps a lot and then it stays and
nothing is happening so may sometimes
you need to go to really high numbers
but then it doesn't change for a long
time you conclude that it's converge but
again this is not not rigorous but it is
very useful the numbers are the number
of states that you're keeping the bond
election oh well here it's a in matrix
products they would correspond to the
bond dimension here is the number of
number of states that I've yeah it is
this dimension for MPS the way to do
things is a variational and matrix
products states so this is what picture
that Zeph was showing you've got a
matrix products data matrix products
state and I want to calculate the
expectation value of a Hamiltonian
something I want to minimize so for
example when these two particles are
interacting I need to sum this up these
two particles interacting I summit I
need to sum this this network this
network and so on and I want to see how
well I'm doing all together all these
summations in some way they're creating
like an effective Hamiltonian and i need
to divide this by the more of the state
and i'm looking for the best possible
matrix here and this is doable
numerically and then you sweep you keep
going like let's let's optimize this guy
let's optimize this type keep calling a
couple times and you've got the best
ambience that you can get numerically
and it works for example in quantum
chemistry computations with either with
the MiG or with the matrix product
states this is what the garnet chance
group is doing or what valentin mork & H
llegas are doing in a Vienna and
Budapest so there it is that you've got
electrons that are supposed to be in
several different orbitals so you can
imagine how or the orbitals could
interact so you got some interaction
between them and you need to find the
best association of hug which orbitals
are occupied and which are which are not
and there could be entanglement between
these things and you don't do it on the
line but you instead of like you these
are the different possible orbitals that
could be occupied or not and you spread
them and make them interactions like on
a tree instead of instead of like
threading a line in there and somehow
the effective distance from one place to
another is just like block size of the
describing of optimizing the Hamiltonian
what's the problem so this is now I'm
trying to find the ground state energy
of a Hamiltonian that involves
interacting electrons the it can be
translated to the local Hamiltonian
problem it can be translated actually in
the fall into the 400 total Hamiltonian
problem exactly to the embassy done that
for us the chemists have done that for
us they have calculated the coefficients
and now we are applying this machinery
to this for local Hamiltonian problem
and the machinery that we apply is just
not direct matrix products States but
matrix photo but tensor net or three
tensor network networks and it is what i
wanted to show just when you put like 16
de minutes bond dimension 16 then the
error goes down again you get like 10 to
the minus 14 for benchmark little small
photochemistry system sorry can you go
back one slide like are you I'm not sure
what's the relation between what you've
done earlier and the MRG and here it's
in the cure optimizing overall mps
states yep and either a connection
between these two like how do you
optimize over and mps is related to the
mr gu so here it's like i have a
particle i have lots of matrices and i
right now are optimizing one particular
one and i move to the next one in the
DMR g this thing is not see the inside
internal structure is not seen its seen
as a big block and with this summation I
for example like this summing this term
is involved in the cost of the left book
that we were talking with the way Thomas
about the price will let block so here
in matrix products that you can
calculate everything you've got these
you get these matrices in the MRG you've
got a thing together you don't see this
line you see just a big book but they're
very related so can you just explain how
variation and mps works in like a more
detailed ok let's let's let's let's end
our end the talk here so the Hamiltonian
has terms that involve particular spin
Staind one and two it's been two and
three and three and four and so on so to
calculate this from here I need to sum
all that yeah so when you look at think
of it is just in something as a formula
so it's a formula dated some big tensor
and then twice the little matrix because
it's linear it's just sampled a lot of
terms okay so this is this and this
might not have been normalized properly
so i need to divide it by the node so
you need to minimize this a way to do it
is that you put in there some lambda you
differentiate with respect to this you
can get a linear equation that's a
generalized eigenvalue problem something
like this x that is some matrix tons
this and some header and the energy so
it's fun it's possible to do it okay hi
there's plenty more that we can discuss
with the people that are they stayed
here because I actually didn't even get
to my to my third party but what really
how well these things are doing how you
contract pets and then possibly what you
can do with the computer is a simulator
so let's just end up here I want you to
channel show you the different
variations of the local Hamiltonian and
all of you turn your attention to the
possibly intermediate ones I try to give
you at least a hint of what are the
algorithms that we are using in practice
and also tell you that we really don't
have many where we know that works I
would even want a very good one and
maybe not a very good one just an
exponential one a quantum algorithm for
finding the ground state of local
Hamiltonians besides just go research
and our phase estimation so something
different something that will be more
natural and then that's a topic for the
whole different talk or I'll just saw
the jump X will continue with like how
do you simulate stuff with hamiltonians
or
you seem apartments ok Joe so you know
there's this paper visually by Matthias
prior and co-authors and I'd say rather
pessimistic about well I wasn't talking
about that one okay I'm talking about
the one about quantum chemistry and
they're rather pessimistic about using
quantum algorithms to compute the brown
singers be a large molecule because they
say although it's polynomial algorithm
it scales like the number of orbitals to
the ninth power and so I guess question
is you think that it's just that you
know we need to optimize the algorithms
and get a better scaling do you think
there's some fundamental reason why we
stuck bit of huge Paula scaling is there
a reason that we whisk up stuck with a
very badly scaling polynomial algorithm
for either in quantum chemistry or maybe
even like you know contracting pets like
the infinite times the best best
algorithm we've got like I think
something goes like D to the 12 and in
the chemistry will be D to the nine
right so you can we know that in the
worst case it's terrible we might find
something this is something this matter
I know I don't see really a fundamental
obstacle of course like their little
things like you know in the chemistry so
there's been this this paper where they
did something with just two photons and
they calculate in the air
is very precisely for for a hydrogen
molecule and they did with a very very
high precision with iterative fav
estimation and this is this is the
proposal that how a condo chemistry
could be done for larger molecules but
for that you really need like many many
more things and for the phase estimation
to go to higher precision you really
need to make many many many terms so
maybe something better can be done but I
don't know this is probably like the
best propose that we have done you know
even for contracting these sensor
networks for contracting these steps
there might be more clever methods that
we just haven't figured out there are
ones that we do like make it clustered
and do something within the cluster and
then continue it's not not easy like for
example for the matrix product stays on
the line it's easy to contract but
things are far apart when you make it on
a tree it's harder to contract because
and suddenly you have tensors with more
indices but maybe smaller indices like
smaller sites from the bond is enough
and there's a trade-off between that and
we need to find the best best spot yeah
so you sang the praises of the emerging
I sleep but it's your 60 must fail on
some cases so are there certain parties
which it is currently so are there
someone be systems on which the MRG does
poorly you know like the worst case are
the critical system that we know and
there it takes it converges slower so we
will need to take more states or just
even the diagonalization like finding
the best state when we form the
effective Hamiltonian takes longer just
debt itself that's the moment step but
it still works like we get we get stuff
with very high precision in minutes or
in dollars on to today's systems so
really I think like that aha or a
conjecture that the really hard ones
would come from higher dimensional
particles so once you get to like Q
quartz q sink weeds or culated or
something maybe not for just pays one
off so conceivable that it is real I'm
Albert this notion or but first a what
have I for one dimension not necessarily
two stages yep so this is something
something that all that we know like for
example for the the one where we can do
the MP computation with our win orbits
maybe the interest of letting you know
doing justice with John stock we could
postpone any further questions until
lunchtime that's like